[Music]
back to our Abby Lee Miller exclusive
we're picking up right where we left off
in the operating room with the former
Dance Moms star as she takes this
drastic step to lose weight so we've
just entered her abdomen the surgery
takes just 45 minutes
80% of Abby Lee stomach is removed
reducing it from the size of a football
to a banana I'm in pain
knocking ly it's not a throbbing pain
it's just kind of a discomfort dr.
Michael Russo performed the surgery he
says it went perfectly and Abby's pain
is normal the sleeve itself doesn't
really hurt her that can cause some
nausea but the main pain is with the
incision the best way to describe how
she feels it's like she did a thousand
sit-ups Abby's weight loss will be
immediate her diet severely restricted
what do you have to give up what do you
have to change you think I'm on a liquid
diet okay for three weeks so how do you
feel about that the silence I know they
said to buy a shot glass and what put
the water and the protein shakes and
these little milkshakes in the shot
glass and drink it one ounce at a time
so I'm just gonna do shots for three
weeks once she's off a liquid diet
planning her meals will get complicated
Abby Lee's sentencing for bankruptcy
fraud is scheduled for May 8 prison time
is possible and they may not accommodate
her new special diet what about in the
long term um you know good proteins yeah
no fats it's the same diet you've heard
for you know the no potatoes the no rice
the no noodles we'll figure it out you
know mama June did a whole show about
her weight-loss journey I know that's
you know I can see it then I saw the
interview afterwards she still sounds
the same now what no you know losing
weight it's not gonna change that not
nice so I just excited that you got you
caught me by surprise again would you
consider something like that like to
document the weight-loss journey maybe
for uh
[Music]